[Musique]
bonjour alors pourquoi je suis ici
lorsque les personnes de l'équipe ted
dunkerque l'ont contacté pour peut venir
m'exprimer devant vous j'avoue j'ai
ignoré ce qu'était ted
je n'ai pas la télé depuis plus de 30
ans et je lis peu les magazines je suis
peu au fait de ce qui est tendance de ce
qui est à la mode mais j'ai quand même
internet
alors je suis allé je suis allé regarder
sur internet
et là je suis tombé sur des mots
technology entertainment design
je suis tombé sur bill gates microsoft
apple et là je me suis dit mais oh la la
qu'est-ce que je vais aller raconter à
ces gens est ce que ce n'est pas plutôt
le monde duquel j'essaie de m'affranchir
alors je suis allé un peu plus loin sur
le site
et puis il ya une phrase une phrase qui
a retenu mon attention
et cette phrase c'était partager
diffuser des idées qui valent d'être
partagée et là je me suis dit oui oui je
peux aller les voir oui j'ai des choses
à leur raconter j'ai des idées qui sont
peut être intéressante sans doute
originale des idées un peu à rebrousse
poil des idées qui sont susceptibles de
changer le regard que nous portons à
l'existence je suis venu vous parler de
deux tentera alors qu'est ce que c'est
que le tantra
il ya trois mots à retenir trois mots
essentiels le premier ses expériences le
second c'est conscient c'est le 3e c'est
vitalité expérience conscience et
vitalité expérience parce que c'est une
démarche empirique c'est une démarche où
on apprend sur soi par l'expérience
conscience parce que le but du jeu c'est
d'être de plus en plus conscients de
comment je fonctionne qui je suis et
comment je réagis aux stimulations
extérieures
le troisième mot c'est vitalité vitalité
parce que dans l'expérience en étant
conscient on se donne la possibilité de
maintenir à un niveau élevé sa vitalité
à leur vitalité c'est pas bouger partout
courir chanter tout le temps c'est ça
peut être quelque chose de beaucoup plus
intérieure c'est être en permanence en
contact avec ses émotions ses sensations
et ses ressentis voilà trois noms à
retenir expérience conscience et
vitalité
alors y'a il ya autant de formes de 2
tentera que que de gens qui
qu'ils le transmettent parce que
finalement on enseigne que que ce qu'on
est
mais moi je distingue quand même trois
grands courants dans le dans cet univers
du tentera il ya deux courants qui sont
des courants traditionnels
le premier c'est le le courant issu de
l'inde ancienne qui aujourd'hui subsiste
sous la forme de certains yoga peut-être
vous avez entendu parler de kundalini
yoga soir à yoga on dit même que le
hatha yoga est un yoga qui est largement
influencée par la doctrine tantrique il
ya aussi ce courant spirituel qui a
fleuri au moyen-âge et puis à la
renaissance au cachemire indien et qui
s'appelle le chiva isme non duel du
cachemire le second le second courant
traditionnelle c'est le vajrayana c'est
le véhicule de diamants qui est un
courant complètement intégré dans la
tradition bouddhiste
mais ces deux courants finalement non
non pas grand chose à voir en apparence
avec le troisième courant celui auquel
j'appartiens et que je vais vous
présenter ce soir c'est celui d'une et
haute en train le néo temps tracer une
interprétation occidentalisée de ces
courants traditionnels une une
interprétation qui se situerait au
croisement du développement personnel du
monde de la thérapie et de la
spiritualité
alors quand je vous parle de
spiritualité je suis pas ici pour vous
vendre une religion
ce dont je vous parle c'est d'une
spiritualité laïque une spiritualité
expérimental par laquelle on on apprend
dans l'expérience à se connaître
je crois que j'ai assez parlé à propos
de tantra et j'ai envie de de partager
un peu de d'expériences et de pratiques
avec vous alors je vais vous faire une
proposition va pratiquer maintenant vous
allez vous tourner vers votre voisin
votre voisine et vous allez juste vous
vous tournez quand même de manière à ce
que le buste puisse pivoter un petit peu
quelqu'un de préférence que vous ne
connaissez pas allez-y
trouver quelqu'un va on va s'en sortir
ok et quand quand vous avez choisi la
personne vous laisser les mots et vous
plonger votre regard dans son regard
juste ça vous plonger votre regard dans
le regard de cette personne ok allez-y
faites le juste en silence en mots pas
besoin de mots regardez plonger votre
regard dans le regard de votre
partenaire et vous observez vous
observez votre respiration vous observez
votre posture corporelle vous observez
aussi les pensées qui vous traversent
les émotions
et vous garder ce contact des regards et
on va passer à une deuxième étape mais
garder ce contact des regards et la
deuxième étape c'est ça va être de
partager un toucher du bout des doigts
alors je vous assure tout se passera
bien
donc vous continuez vous laisser les
mots de nouveau vous vous replonger dans
le contact des regards et seulement pour
les personnes qui sont d'accord avec ce
contact du bout des doigts
si vous le sentez pas vous le faites pas
vous rester juste dans le contact des
regards si vous vous sentez que c'est
possible pour vous d'être en contact du
bout des doigts je dis bien juste du
bout des doigts
vous mettez vos deux mains à hauteur des
épaules les doigt vers le ciel les
paumes vers votre partenaire et vous
approchez doucement les mains vous
approchez tout doucement les mains le
plus lentement possible
allez-y faites le maintenant et vous
rester comme ça immobile pendant un
instant dans le contact des regards ne
me regardez plus je vous assure je vais
vous donner les indications en parlant
vous n'avez plus besoin de me regarder
regarder l'autre
et puis maintenant vous allez laisser
venir un mouvement un mouvement de vos
avant-bras peut-être un mouvement de
votre buste vous allez organiser comme
une danse autour autour de vos doigts
une danse lente
voyez quelques fois on peut se mettre à
rire à masquer sa gêne par des
mouvements un peu plus ample c'est ok ok
on va s'arrêter là vous pouvez me
regarder maintenant
alors comment c'était qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour vous est ce que vous
avez pu
est ce que vous avez pu observer votre
respiration est ce qu'elle a accéléré
est ce que votre respiration c'est
complètement coupées ou figées est ce
que votre respiration est restée
naturelle est ce que est ce que vous
avez gardé le contact des regards où
est-ce que c'était tellement gênant que
votre regard était obligé de partir
ailleurs
comment était votre posture corporelle
est ce que vous étiez pencher vers
l'autre est ce que vous étiez en retrait
est ce que vous êtes resté tranquille
dans votre verticalité comme en été vous
pensez qu est ce qui s'est passé dans
votre tête est ce que il ya eu de l'élan
danville envie d'aller vers est ce qu'il
y a eu plutôt de la résistance et se
dire mais j'ai envie d'être un peu plus
loin je voudrais pas avoir commencé à
toucher
est ce que vous m'avez pris pour un fou
parce que ça c'est une option aussi
voilà eh bien le tantra c'est ça le
tantra c'est apprendre à observer dans
l'expérience et apprendre à observer
dans l'expérience pourquoi pour être
plus conscients et ramener ça dans sa
vie
à quoi ça sert la conscience est bien
quand on est plus conscient de dans sa
vie dans chaque instant alors on peut
faire des choix on peut faire des choix
par exemple quand vous êtes en couple
quand vous êtes en relation et que vous
commencez à réaliser à quel point vous
êtes en dépendance affective
alors je vais caricaturé à quel point
vous avez besoin d'entendre dix fois par
jour je t'aime ou dix fois par jour tu
es beau brillant à ce moment là vous
pouvez commencer à à dire ok je vais
prendre responsabilité de me nourrir à
cet endroit là d'alimenter moi même mon
insécurité vous savez dans le
développement personnel
on appelle ça l'estiment de soi et les
avantages de ça c'est que vous cessez de
faire porter la responsabilité à l'autre
dans la relation de vous nourrir aux
endroits où vous n'avez pas été et vous
vous donnez aussi l'option de ne plus
vouloir à la personne de ne plus en
vouloir à la personne de ne pas être
disponibles affectivement quand vous
vous en avez besoin
donc c'est une transformation radicale
dans la relation il ya un autre point
que je voudrais aborder par rapport à la
pratique que nous venons d'avoir ces
jeux pas si vous avez remarqué mais à un
moment je vous ai dit mais vous n'êtes
pas obligé de partager ce contact
physique c'est ok de pas faire parce que
ça quand on aborde le néo tentera en
particulier c'est un quelque chose de
fondamental nos limites
c'est des choses qu'on a construite dans
notre histoire des choses qu'on a
construite pour pour nous protéger
contre probablement des agressions
extérieures dans notre enfance et c'est
des choses qui viennent souvent se
réactive et à juste titre parce que ce
sont des protections et ça nous défend
contre des choses qui ne nous
conviennent pas le problème le problème
c'est que ces limites quelquefois elles
viennent se réactiver à des endroits où
elles n'ont absolument pas lieu d'être
où elles ne sont pas s'approprier et
c'est nos peurs par exemple nous peur et
lorsqu'elle se manifeste de cette
manière là elle nous empêche de vivre
alors le tantra ça nous amène à la
rencontre de ses limites
ça nous amène à l'est peut-être d'abord
prendre conscience de ses limites à les
reconnaître à les faire respecter
c'est à dire si j'ai pas envie de faire
je ne fais pas pour peut-être un jour
commençait à aller au-delà des limites
mais au delà des limites on y va très
bien que si on y va à son rythme dans
son temps ça ne sert à rien de franchir
trop brutalement ses limites
pourquoi parce que si vous franchissez
trop brutalement vos limites à ce moment
là vous allez réouvrir de vieilles
blessures
vous allez créer de la rigidité nouvelle
alors que la recherche c'est plutôt
d'être fluide avec l'existence je ne
voudrais pas vous parler de tentera sans
aborder la question de la sexualité
parce que dallaire dans la présentation
ça a été fait au moment où j'ai évoqué
le mot tentera je pense qu'il y avait la
moitié de la salle qu'il connaissait pas
et puis peut-être l'autre moitié l'a
associé à l'idée de sexualité et à juste
titre c'est vrai que quand on parle de
tantra on associe souvent ça à sexualité
pourquoi parce que le tantra c'est une
voie spirituelle qui n'exclut pas la
sexualité dans sa pratique les voies
traditionnelles considère que la
cérémonie de la sexualité est un
achèvement après dix quinze ans de
pratique de méditation de pranayama
c'est-à-dire de techniques de
respiration
le néo tentera va utiliser quelquefois
des massages dans la pratique à des fins
de conscience pour bien prendre
conscience de comment on fonctionne dans
les interactions mais ça ça représente
5% 10% de la pratique pas plus c'est
marginal simplement comme on est dans
une société complètement névrosé autour
de la sexualité on ne pense plus qu'à ça
quand on parle de temps en train alors
je vais me présenter je m'appelle
laurent lacoste je suis un pur un pur
produit du système élitiste dans lequel
nous vivons
j'ai fait les grandes écoles j'étais
banquier pendant 20 ans et j'étais un
spécialiste des financements pétrolier
et gazier
autant vous dire que dans le monde du
développement personnel dans lequel
j'évolue aujourd'hui je suis le diable
et en même temps autant le tantra ça m'a
donné beaucoup de recul par rapport à ce
monde que j'ai quitté autant le monde
que j'ai quitté me donne aussi de du
recul par rapport au monde au petit
monde du développement personnel dans
lequel j'évolue aujourd'hui je voudrais
conclure conclure en vous disant que et
en vous rappelant que pour moi le tantra
c'est une voie d'expansion de la
conscience mais c'est une voie à brut
c'est une voie de déprogrammation de
déconditionnement donc elle n'est pas
bonne pour tout le monde et si jamais un
jour vous décidez de vous lancer dans
dans l'expérience
choisissez bien travaillé fait ce
travail avec des gens qui vous pouvez
avoir confiance enseigne et vaut autour
de vous écouter le bouche à oreille
parler à vos amis
en même temps c'est pas si compliqué que
ça et puis je voudrais faire aussi un
lien avec le thème de cette soirée
le thème de cette soirée c'est nos modes
et nos mondes de consommation alors eh
bien le tantra c'est à la mode et c'est
pour c'est probablement la raison pour
laquelle j'ai été invité à venir vous
parler c'est à la mode mais j'ai oui ça
m'arrange puisque j'ai envie mais j'ai
surtout une attention c'est que ça ne
devienne pas un produit de consommation
courante que ça reste une voie une voie
de recherche sur soi une voie de
développement de la conscience afin que
nous prenons un peu de recul par rapport
à l'existant c'est que nous arrêtions de
courir comme des hamsters dans nos roues
la tête baissée que pendant un moment
nous puissions sortir de la roue lever
la tête et vivre je vous remercie de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]